Halloween's coming up and I know for you
it's a really big exciting time because
it's also Halloween night on dancer that
starts juniors yes what are you going to
tell me about the routine that you're
doing and also your costume yeah
so the routine I'll be doing is the PAS
so it's a very like strong oh yeah type
of dance I will be just in up as mouth
from defending okay my partner our time
so it seems to be dressing up as Carlos
I'm super excited because it's Halloween
and Halloween is my favorite holiday
I'm super excited for you guys to hear I
will so descendants you and dub Cameron
actually worked together I know I'm
living Maddie how cool is that to
channel your former co-star it's amazing
I mean Liv and Maddie was my first gig I
ever booked man it was on Disney Channel
and doug has been the sweetest ever
since throughout the years she's so kind
to me and she's like a big sister you
know yeah I'm so being able to do a
movie that she's in it was such a cool
experience now does she know that you're
doing this or is it a complete surprise
for her I think it's a complete surprise
for her act he's gonna love this so when
she watches on Sunday I think it's
awesome you're gonna channel your
co-star dub however for girls that maybe
you don't have a costume yet I think it
would be so cool for them to dress up as
you as young Gamora and a vendor skin
Finity or um that's a fantastic idea I
mean it would be so cool to see a little
more walking yeah I definitely think if
you guys want a costume you can
definitely go south the awesome
now what happens you have for them like
what do they need to get the perfect
costume you get the perfect young Gamora
costume I think you should definitely
get a green face please
okay when will one we have a picture
right here of this oh wow yeah so
obviously it took done like two hours
and then obviously more things in the
prosthetics right here on the brow bone
as you can see right here so you can
definitely see the different shades and
make the airbrushing right here on the
prosthetics just to make my facial
structures in
and alien yeah but if they get face
paint at the store say they can probably
do that in under an hour for sure right
just like get three colors I get silver
I think so let's see them metal under
the iron that's good call that's a
little tip um you just green all over
the face and then you can give it like
to mention the different shades again
okay yeah now what about this hair that
you got going on over here oh my gosh
it's just all in my favorite part
because I'm obsessed with me alright now
that I wear a wig that is this pretty
they had all these different wigs and
they just put them on me okay now for
the actual outfit what do they need I
think you could definitely get away with
wearing like a purple it's like a pro
bono Jackalopes okay and then you can do
it you can wear like purple leggings or
purple like jeans or sweatpants on it
and that would work perfectly and then
can just wear like ankle like kind of
like these size boots and just just
rocking it like you don't have to be
identical and perfect as long as you
feel good about yourself
and I'm younger more I'm rocking the
street
[Music]